- You don't drink coffee?
- [Nick] No,
- I don't trust anybody
who doesn't drink coffee.
This interview's over.
- My name is Nick Barili and
I'm traveling the country
to sit down with some of
the biggest Latinx artists
in places that have meaning to them
and help tell their stories.
We'll talk about their
journeys and careers
and explore issues of identity, culture,
discrimination, and representation.
This is "SEEN".
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, we're back.
I am on campus at Cal State
Northridge, also known as CSUN.
I am on my way to meet Eva
Longoria, a true multi hyphenate.
Actress, director, producer,
entrepreneur, philanthropist.
So many different hats.
The place she chose for us to
meet is Jerome Richfield Hall.
Let's go find out why.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, hello!
- How are you doing?
Pleasure to meet you.
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Good.
- So Jerome Richfield Hall,
of all the places in LA
that we've could have met, why
is this the place you picked?
- You know what?
CSUN is a very special place for me.
It's where I got my masters.
And this particular building
is the Chicano studies hall.
And CSUN was the first university
to have a Chicano studies program.
- Wow, I didn't know that.
- It's the first in the country
and so it's the best in the country.
This place was probably the
place I grew most in my life.
- What does it feel like
to be on campus again
after 10 years ago or 15 years ago
when you got your masters?
- I'm not that old Nick.
No, but it was 10 years ago.
(laughs)
- All right, great, I
thought I did my research.
- But its not 15 years ago.
But actually makes me exhausted
'cause I was exhausted
the whole time I was here.
- You were actually attending here
while you were working on "Housewives"?
- Yeah, yeah, I did night school.
I would finish filming and
come here 7 to 10 at night
and then go home and then do it all again.
Be on set at 5 AM and it fills my heart
with my Mexican pride.
- Well I wanna talk more
about what it was like
during those days and why
you picked Chicano studies.
But let's go inside.
- Okay, come inside 'cause
there's the most beautiful mural
that made my heart swell
every time I saw it.
(upbeat music)
Oh my God, it smells the same.
- Really?
- Look, so this is Ballet Folklorico.
I always wanted to do it as a kid.
We couldn't afford to do it.
My mom was like, "It's too expensive",
and so when I got my masters,
we had to pick an art.
I chose Ballet Folklorico and I danced.
Oh my God, this is my adviser,
Christina Ayala-Alcantar.
She's amazing, she's still here.
But I wanna show you the mural.
(upbeat music)
- Tada!
- Wow, this is the mural
you were talking about.
- This is the mural.
(upbeat music)
- That's Dr. Acūna.
He's the godfather of Chicano studies.
His book is what made me
wanna study Chicano studies,
was called "Occupied America".
And it was the history of our people.
- It's crazy that growing up in Texas
and I grew up in
California that that's not
a part of our curriculum.
- That's part of the
struggle with Chicano studies
is getting our community
to learn our history.
It's a fight.
They're taking it away
in Arizona and Texas.
I mean, they're saying
you should not learn this.
And so that's part of this
whole movement is to make sure
that we do learn our history.
(upbeat music)
- I met you briefly like 10 years ago.
Sure you don't remember,
but it was at Beso
and you were honoring the farm workers
in Dolores that night.
- [Eva] Yes.
And I was so inspired that
at a moment in your career
when all the light was on you,
you took that light and
used it to empower others.
What point in your career
did that really become
a mission for you?
- It's probably when I moved to LA.
The pride in California is very different.
Like the word Chicano
comes from California,
the movement originated in California.
And one of the first people
I met was Dolores Huerta .
- [Nick] Oh wow.
- Yeah, I wasn't famous.
I was just asking her
questions about her legacy
and her work.
And she said, "You know, one
day you're gonna have a voice
so you better have something to say",
and I never forgot that.
And then you know, later on,
to actually have that platform
to be able to bring attention
to causes that are near
and dear to me has been an honor.
(slow music)
- [Nick] Would love to
go into the classroom.
- Yes!
As tired as I used to be
walking into a classroom,
the minute I walked in, I was
like, "I'm going to learn!"
I was like, that's the benefit
of being an older student
is that you're eager and you're curious,
and you're like a sponge
as opposed to being like 21
and you're like, "I
just want to graduate".
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- If you had to look back,
what do you think that time
taught you about yourself?
- You know, that you're
capable of it anything.
I mean, the reality is you
have more time in the day
than you think.
It's the amount of time
you waste in the day.
And the other thing it taught me was
you're never too old to learn.
You're never too old to
finish something or to go back
and do something or to try something new.
And so that's what really,
I think the biggest message
that came out of it was like,
I was, "I'm gonna do this.
I can do this, I did it". You know?
- How did that set you up for
all your future endeavors?
Because now you're multi hyphenate.
Not only do you act,
you direct, you produce,
you're entrepreneur,
you're philanthropist.
- I think for the most part, like I said,
my thesis became the
basis of my foundation.
And so to have research really
backing your initiatives
to say I studied what our community needs
and that's where I'm going
to focus my energy on
'cause I want to make
sustainable effective change.
That's where it probably
helped me the most.
It also made me a little bit more credible
my political activism.
Like I knew what I was talking about.
I knew the history, I knew the policies.
And I continue to stay educated on that
because the fight never
ends for our community.
And so it's done a lot for me.
- I heard that one of the things
that powered you through was coffee.
- Yeah.
- I haven't had coffee
since I was a PA in college.
- You don't drink coffee?
- [Nick] No,
- I don't trust anybody
who doesn't drink coffee.
This interview's over.
Come and see my coffee machine.
(curious music)
.Tada!
- So this is the actual coffee
machine when you were here?
- Yes! This was my coffee spot you guys.
It tasted like shit, I can't
believe this is still here.
I don't think they've
changed out the coffee since,
but I would take-
- Are we doing this?
- Let's buy one.
But yeah, oh gosh.
It takes credit cards.
I don't think it took credit cards back.
Maybe it takes Apple pay now.
Totally takes Apple pay!
- Its not connected to the internet?
(laughs)
- We can't Apple pay.
- This gonna be the whole video.
It's just two people trying to get coffee.
- Y'all we've gotta taste this coffee.
So look what happens.
- [Nick] Wow.
(laughs)
- All right, let's see.
Okay.
Oh man!
- Takes you back?
- Smell that, you don't care.
- Smells like coffee.
- See, to me it smells like late nights.
That's what it smells like.
All right, we gotta get you
one and then we should go
have our coffee break.
I'll show you where I
actually used to sit outside.
- Would love to.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to the courtyard.
- So this is where sometimes
you would hang out before class?
- Sometimes.
I was usually rushing,
but the times I did get
to have a little bit of time, this was it.
It was crowded every
single seat was taken.
(upbeat music)
- Let's take it back.
I would love to get a little
bit of context in your life.
I always love in interviews
pretending that it's a movie of your life.
- Who's playing me?
- You're playing you.
- I'm playing me.
Oh my God, I've always
wanted me to play me!
(laughs)
- That opening scene that
comes into Corpus Christi
interior childhood home.
What are we seeing?
What are we hearing?
What are we smelling?
- I'm from Corpus Christi.
But I was really raised on the ranch,
which is outside of Corpus Christi.
So we grew up with cows
and chickens and pigs.
Yeah, I mean we were from the ranch.
My swimming pool was
the cow trough of water.
That's where we're like, "We're so lucky"!
We have a swimming pool.
Corpus Christi is a really
small town in Texas.
I grew up in a Mexican neighborhood.
And so I remember,
never really feeling Mexican
'cause there was no need
to say it, we were all just
in that neighborhood together.
And it wasn't until the third grade,
when I tested into a gifted
and talented program,
so I had to go to a
school way across town.
- Take me to that first day,
that first day you're getting on the bus.
- On the school bus.
- On the school bus to go there.
- I remember getting on the
school bus and every morning
to this day - this morning
I ate this breakfast.
This is the same
breakfast I eat every day.
It was a bean taco, no cheese,
just a flour tortilla and beans.
Every morning I eat for breakfast.
And my mom would make it for
me and I'd take it to school
and I'd eat it.
And so I got on the bus with my bean taco.
Everybody was staring at me
and everybody had a pop tart.
Everybody had one and I go,
"Oh my God, what is that?"
They looked at me and
they're like, "What's that?"
And I was like, "It's the bean taco?
Don't you get it?
Doesn't everybody eat a bean taco?"
And they were like, "No."
And I remember a little
girl on the bus going,
"She's Mexican."
And I didn't know what that meant.
I didn't know the word,
I was like, "What?"
So that was the first
time I felt like other.
I was like, "Oh, oh, okay."
And I think there was like two
Mexicans in the whole school.
- So you come home from school that day?
- Yeah.
- What's that conversation
like with your mom?
- Oh, I begged my mom to buy pop tarts.
I was like, "Mom, you gotta buy pop tarts.
I don't wanna bean taco anymore."
She was like, "We're not buying pop tarts.
Here's two bean tacos for tomorrow."
And so yeah, I just
remember going, oh my gosh,
I'm different and I didn't know why.
- What was it like at that moment
kind of straddling both worlds?
I mean, you're in a neighborhood
that's predominantly Mexican.
You're going to school
that's predominantly affluent and white.
- I also think it's confusing.
to them, by the way, not to me,
because I didn't have an accent.
I'm white passing.
So they're like, "You don't look Mexican,
you don't sound Mexican."
And it was kind of the same reception
I had when I came to Hollywood.
Yeah, they were like, "Oh,
so could you do that with an accent?"
And I'd be like, "I don't have an accent"
or "Could you do it in Spanish?"
And I didn't speak Spanish.
And so they're like,
"Well, how are you Hispanic
and not speak Spanish?"
I'm like, "There's a lot of
us that don't speak Spanish."
I've since learned it
but at that moment coming to Hollywood,
I would never get the Latin roles
'cause I wasn't Latin enough.
And then I wouldn't get the white roles
because I was too Latin.
I played a lot of Italians.
- Speak about your parents' decision
to not teach you Spanish
in an attempt to assimilate
because I feel like that
happened to a lot of people
that grew up here.
- Yeah, especially in Texas.
I'm ninth generation American.
I never crossed a border,
the border crossed us.
And so when people go,
"Go home!", we're like,
"No, we are home."
- This is home.
My family was under five different flags
without ever moving.
From Spain to Mexico, to France,
to Republic of Texas, to America.
And so for a lot of Texans
assimilation was key.
Assimilation was important.
So my parents felt that they said,
"We don't want you to
be discriminated against
because you speak Spanish."
And so they spoke Spanish to each other
but they wouldn't speak it to us.
And we were an English only household.
And I never learned it
until my adult life,
until I married a Mexican.
(laughs)
- When was the first time
that you turned on a TV
or watched a movie that
you felt seen as a Latina
and you felt proud to be Latina?
- It was probably like
Salma Hayek in Desperados
or it was like pretty late in life.
I remember Rita Moreno
right in West Side Story,
but I wasn't Puerto Rican so
I kinda didn't understand it.
I was like, "Oh! Mm, no."
And they brown faced them
on that original movie.
And I remember even Rita
talking about it of like,
"Why are you making us so dark?"
And I just thought, I
actually remember thinking
"They're a weird color."
But yeah, growing up,
it was very, very few.
- Yeah, same when I first saw "La Bamba",
that was like the first time I was like...
And I was a Mexican but I was
like the Latino experience
I could relate to.
- So it was like, but you
know I was lucky growing up
in Corpus with Selena.
Selena was one or two years older than me.
And so growing up with her
and seeing her trajectory,
we used to see her play at
quinceaneras and weddings,
so it wasn't a big deal.
But once she started
blowing up and becoming big,
I thought that, I really
saw myself in Selena
because she was a "Texican" like I was.
And she really embraced being Latina.
And so it was just like,
I was like, "Yes, her,
I want to be like her!", you know?
- Right, speaking of quinceaneras.
- Quinceaneras.
- My accent come and goes.
Wanting to do yours, you
went to go work at Wendy's.
- Yes.
- What was that like?
- Yes, it was crazy
because I wasn't old enough
to get a job.
So I stole my sister's ID and
I went and applied and got it.
And I didn't wanna tell
my parents cause I knew
they'd get mad.
I worked there for like two
weeks without them knowing
until one of my teachers
came in and she saw me
and she told my parents like-
- She's a little young to be working.
And my mom was like,
"Did you go get a job?"
And I was like, "Yes".
And so, I mean, it was legal.
All she had to do was
I had to get permission
from my parents to work.
So I was like, "Mom, please,
I want a quinceanera"
because they wouldn't pay for it.
My mom and dad were like "Your sister
didn't get a quinceanera, you're
not getting a quinceanera."
I mean, they're weddings,
they're as expensive as weddings.
And I was like, "I want a quinceanera."
So I got a job to make my own quinceanera
And I did that, yes.
- [Nick] Where does that
work ethic come from?
- My work ethic comes from my mom.
My mom is like, I still to this day,
think I don't do enough because
I just see what my mom did
without a cell phone and
without all the technology
that we have today, she's super.
I don't know how she did it.
She was always there.
And so I don't remember a
day without my mom working
as hard as she could.
And she was always very efficient.
My mom would say, "I'm
gonna go into the bank.
You're gonna go into the
store, get the tomatoes,
I'll meet you with the cash register."
I mean, she got everything done.
She maximized the day.
- She was a natural producer.
I think about that from my mom too.
I mean, my mom was a single mom,
went to school and she was a professor
and she did all this
stuff and she had a job
and then she came home and
helped me with my homework.
And I was like, I look back and I'm like,
how did you have time to do all that
and still be present in my life?
- Yeah, super moms, it
was a different era.
- What was the point
where you started to think
that being an actress
or coming to Hollywood
was something that you wanted for you?
- It was overnight one day.
I didn't dream of it, I
didn't grow up with it.
We never went to the
movies when I was young.
We didn't have that, oh,
look at the movie stars.
Celebrity culture wasn't a thing.
And so role models growing up
for me was my family, my mom,
my sister, my aunt.
I didn't really look
up to Hollywood people.
I didn't even know what that meant.
And I'd never really
been outside of Texas.
And so in college I ran out
of money my senior year.
I was like, "I want to
finish, I want to finish."
So my friend was like,
"Hey, you should join
the scholarship pageant."
And I was like, "What's that?"
And she said, "It's like a beauty pageant,
but you get a scholarship if you win."
And I remember like, I just
wanted to get fourth place
because fourth place was like books.
- Cover your school.
- So I was like, "If I
could just get fourth place,
okay, that'll be taken care of."
And so they called,
"Fourth place is Jane."
And I was like, "Oh man, now
I'm not gonna win anything."
And then the third place, and
I won, I won the whole thing.
And I was like, "Oh my
God, this is amazing."
So I was happy 'cause I
got to pay my senior year.
But because I won that pageant,
I had to be in another one.
And I was like, "Oh no, I don't wanna-"
- Right, I'm just trying
to pay for college.
- I just wanted to be in this one.
Then I had to go to the next one
which was miss Corpus Christi and I won.
My mom was the one that
was like, "That's it.
No more pageants.
This is not the way I want you to go."
But in my prize package
for miss Corpus Christi
was a trip to Los Angeles.
I just thought, "Oh, that'd be fun."
I didn't think "I'm gonna
be an actor", like nothing.
One of the reasons to come was
this like talent competition.
I was like, "Yeah yeah, I'll
do this talent competition."
But I really just wanted to
go to Hollywood Boulevard
and walk around and see Santa Monica pier.
When I went into the talent competition,
I won everything and all
these managers and agents
wanted to "sign" me.
I was like, "What do you mean sign?"
I don't even know what that means.
And it was 1998, which like
Ricky mania, J-Lo mania.
It was like, to be Latina in
the industry in that moment,
a lot of doors were opening.
So all these agents were
like, "This would be great."
I was like, "What do you mean?"
I didn't even know.
- They had plans for
you you didn't have yet.
- They had plans and dreams
for me I didn't even know of.
And I was lucky, I signed
with somebody good.
And I was like, literally
called my mom on that trip
and I said, "Hey, I'm gonna stay in LA.
I'm gonna be an actor."
Just like that one day, one day.
And she goes, "Okay..."
Because I had just finished
college, my mom was like,
"Well, you'll be fine.
You can get a job anywhere,
you have your degree now."
And I said, "Yeah, yeah,
I'll just go get a job."
That was it literally one day.
And I just never went home.
- Wow.
- I had $23 in my bank
account and I was like,
"Okay, I need a job."
And I went to a temp agency to get a job.
And the temp agency ended
up hiring me to work there.
- As a head hunter.
- As a head hunter, yeah.
- Which you ended up keeping
even after you got young and restless.
- Yeah. 'cause I made more
money head hunting than acting.
And so I was like, "Oh, okay,
let me just keep doing
this to pay my rent."
And I would do my head hunting job
out of my dressing room at CBS.
And I would be on the
phone and on my computer.
And then they're like,
"Eva, camera's ready."
And I'm like "All right!"
And I also had to hide the
fact that I was an actor
from the corporate world,
'cause they always frowned upon actors.
'Cause they were like, "Oh,
you're just a dumb actress"
as opposed to like, "No, I'm smart
and totally capable of this job."
And it wasn't until like, I mean,
two years I was doing both jobs.
And about two years in one
of my clients was like,
are you on "Young and the Restless"?
And I said, "No."
- Through your voice or
they actually saw it?
- I think they saw it
and they saw the name
and they go there's a girl
on "Young and the Restless".
I go, "I know that's not me.
I don't know who that is.
I don't know who that is."
Like I tried to deny it as long as I could
'cause I didn't want them to
think I was a dumb actress.
I was like the opposite of, I was like,
"I don't wanna publicize this.
I don't want anybody knowing because-"
- "Because this is actually
paying my bills over here."
- Yeah, "It's gonna affect my job job.
And I don't want it to affect my job job."
And finally, the third year
being on "Young and the Restless"
I was able to make enough
money to quit my job job.
- When was that moment
that you knew you made
your parents proud with your career?
- Oh, so many.
My mom and my dad, they've
been proud since I was in band
or I was a cheerleader
and they were proud.
But I think when I got my star
on the Hollywood walk of fame,
that was something tangible
that they go, "Oh my God,
that's what happens to
big Hollywood people!"
And I'm like, "Yeah, I'm getting a star!"
And I got that star almost 20 years
to the day that I moved to LA.
- Oh wow.
- And I remember being
on Hollywood Boulevard
when I moved here in 1998 and
I went to Hollywood Boulevard
and I go, you know, one day
I'm gonna have a star here.
And it was like 20 years to the date
almost to the exact spot.
- You manifested it.
- Yeah.
And so they were really proud
of me in that moment as well.
And the other time they
were most proud of me
was when I got my masters.
- I was gonna say, how did they feel?
'Cause you come from a family
that really values education.
How did they feel when you told them
I'm gonna go get my
masters in Chicano studies.
- My mom constantly bugged me about it.
I'm the last person in my
family to get my masters.
- Wow.
- Definitely, when my parents came here
for the graduation
ceremony, my mom was crying
'cause she was like,
"Wow, it's important."
Education was very
important to our family.
And so that was the other
finest moment for them.
- I would love to talk about,
you've been directing for a while.
You did "Blackish", "Jane the Virgin"
a bunch of like different stuff.
As you were working for your
first feature directing role,
I was reading that you
really had to set yourself up
for that role for "Flamin' Hot".
Can you walk me through that process?
I heard that that a couple
people kind of like helped you
along the way.
- Oh, so many people, so many people.
I've been directing for 10 years,
but this will be my first
narrative feature link
'cause I've done documentary features.
So it's so funny.
Like you never know you're
not qualified for something
until you go in for a job
and somebody tells you,
"Well, you haven't done it yet!"
Like "Yeah, well I haven't
done it until you do it."
- Exactly.
- So I had to work twice as
hard just to get into the door,
twice as hard on my presentation,
twice as hard on my pitch,
and twice as hard on my vision.
So I was practicing my pitch over and over
and over and over.
I was practicing my pitch
with my friend, Brian Tanen
who's a show runner, big show runner.
And I said, "Okay, Brian,
I'm gonna, do my pitch."
And so I started and
not even one minute in,
he goes, "Okay, I gotta stop you.
I gotta stop you right there."
And I was like, "Yeah?"
And he goes, "I want you walk out the door
and come back in with your
white male privileged pants on.
You're gonna come into this room
and assume you have the job.
You're not coming into this
room and asking for the job.
You're not coming into
this room and begging like,
'Oh please, please give it to me.'
You're coming in and saying,
'When I direct this movie,
this is what I'm gonna do.
My vision for this movie
is going to be this.'"
And it changed not only that pitch,
but every job going forward with that,
it changed in my life.
The way I approach anything that I want.
White male privilege is alive and well.
Any man that comes into that room is like
assumes he has the job,
of course he has a job.
You'll be silly not to have me.
And it really just like
something clicked in my head.
And I went into that room
and I had all the confidence
in the world.
I had every answer, I had every idea.
I had every piece all put
together and presented in a way
that I had to make it undeniable.
That's the only chance
I had, I was a woman.
I was a woman of color.
I was first time director,
like everything's against me.
So what do I gotta lose?
And it worked and I got the job.
Being underestimated is
the best position to be in.
It's the best position to be in.
Like, let's go prove ourselves.
We have to prove ourselves.
And so every day that
I showed up during prep
and on the set and the
filming of that movie
and the editing is like 110%
because I have to prove that
I can do this to people.
I know I can do it,
but I gotta prove to
everybody else that I can.
- Talk about your production company
and now being in a place
where you're consciously
hiring women in minorities, as opposed to
what's been going on
which is unconsciously.
Because a lot of people are like,
"Oh, well we have this problem.
How do we get here?"
And it's like, okay, one of
the reasons why we got here
is because people just the people
that they're used to working with.
So we have to be really
conscious about switching that.
- By the way, I don't think it's like,
I don't think all of
it is systemic racism.
I think a lot of it is unconscious bias.
A lot of it is, "I've worked
with Bill and Tom and Bob.
I'm gonna hire Bill and Tom and Bob."
- 'Cause you're familiar.
- "I'm familiar with them.
I know they can do it."
I remember producing "Grand Hotel"
and they gave me a list of DPs
and they're like oh, here you go.
And it was Bob and Bill and Tom.
And I was like, "Do you
have any female DPs?"
They go, "Oh yeah, yeah,
actually we'll get back to you."
And they brought me five
names and I hired a female DP.
They weren't against the idea.
They weren't like absolutely not.
They were unconsciously ignoring that.
So my production company,
our mission is to produce
with purpose, specifically,
building a pipeline of talent in front of
and behind the camera of Latinos.
We exist, we're here,
we're in this industry.
So I want to be able to
create those job opportunities
for them and give them that experience.
So when they go to the next job, they go,
"I have done this.
I've already done this,
I know how to do this."
And so that's the greatest
thing about being a producer
is job creation.
Like I remember we were on
the set of "Telenovela",
my sitcom and the sets were going up.
The construction crew
was putting up the sets
and I was walking the
sets with a friend of mine
and he goes, "Isn't this crazy?
You had an idea and now
300 people have a job."
And I was like, oh my God, yeah.
I mean, everybody from
construction to your crew
to dry cleaning, to
catering, the way one show
affects the economy and affects
people's economic mobility
is really fascinating to me
and so I enjoy that part of it.
- When I see a show like
"Gentefied" be canceled.
When I see a show like "One
Day at a Time" be canceled.
I feel like, okay, we're
taking steps forward.
But maybe the shows aren't necessarily
getting the promotional
push or other things
to really be around for
seasons and seasons.
How do you think we can
take that next step?
- There's so many factors to those things.
I have been on TV shows
that have been canceled.
I produced "Telenovela", we got canceled.
I produced "Grand Hotel", we got canceled.
I come from the mindset of
build it and they will come.
If we give a show to the Latino audience,
they're gonna show up and
that has not been the case.
And why aren't they showing
up has a number of issues
connected to that.
It's the same reason why we don't vote.
Are we not engaging in our
audience the way we should be?
Are we not welcoming them to the platforms
that these shows are on?
Are we not telling them
when it's on and how it's on
and where they can watch it?
And at the same time,
are they not showing up
because "Gentified" is about
a Mexican-American family
and "I'm Argentinian, I don't get it."
We're a very factioned group.
We're not monolithic.
And I think our community
focuses a lot on the differences
because we wanna prove
that we're not monolithic,
but I love the idea of like,
finding our commonalities.
We have themes within our
community that are universal.
Family, tradition,
culture, food, language.
I mean, we all speak Spanish.
I think there's a little bit of ownership
on our audiences to show up.
If something is out there for us show up,
I don't care what background
you are, support it.
And then at the same time, I agree.
A lot of times we don't get
enough bites at the apple.
So we get one "Gentified" a year.
But why don't we have 10 shows on the air?
And if one gets canceled,
it's not such a casualty to our hearts.
A lot of it's educating the
gatekeepers of our industry,
who are mostly white male.
And so we have to say, "No, no, no.
'La Llorona' is gonna be a
really great, scary movie.
You it's gonna resonate with
everybody, not just Latinos."
And especially with the
way media's consumed today
and made today, there's so many
options and so many outlets.
The only way that you're
gonna break through
as a new show or a movie
is through innovation.
And the only way innovation
happens is by diversity.
And so you can't keep going
back to that same talent pool
for the same story, 'cause
you're gonna get the same movie.
But you can still do Romeo
and Juliet through the eyes
of a Latino as a very different story.
You can do Hamlet through
the eyes of a woman,
it will be very different.
Not only do we have to
educate the gatekeepers,
we gotta change out the gatekeepers
and get us a seat at those tables.
- For sure.
You've accomplished so much
already on the acting side,
directing side, producing side,
entrepreneurial side,
activism side, political side,
what's left for you to accomplish?
Where does your focus go?
- Oh my gosh, on all of it.
I'm gonna continue to do all of it.
So I still have so much I wanna act in,
I still have so much, I
wanna direct and produce.
Political activism will never
go away as our communities
are still underserved
and underrepresented.
My foundation's gonna be my life's work.
That's gonna be my work forever.
And I think, being a mom has
really prioritized my life.
He's the center of my universe.
So everything you now
revolves around that priority
and motherhood and so I
wanna continue to do it all.
- The last question that
I have and is a question
that we've been talking about
in our communities for a while
in terms of waking up the giant.
We've 60 million US Latinos,
yet we don't necessarily have
the political capital that
should come with that.
As someone who's been advocating
for the last 20 years,
what are some of the keys in order to-
- Yeah, I mean, I think
it's voter education.
I mean, I never say I speak
for the Latino community.
I always go out and encourage
the Latino community
to speak for itself.
And the way you speak up
for yourself is by voting,
by participating, civic engagement,
being involved, being informed.
We did a survey of if people
even knew the district
they're in, "Do you know
what district you're in?"
And they're like, "Oh God, no."
"Do you know who your
local representation is?"
And I think a big misconception
for our communities is that
every four years is a general
election for president
and they participate but
what really them day to day
is their local government.
Who is on your school board,
who is on your city council?
That is what's going to affect
your everyday experiences.
People go, "I can't solve world hunger."
No, but you could donate
to your local food bank.
So that homeless guy that
you see at your coffee shop
every morning, you could help him.
Because I think the misconception is
you have to be a
politician to be political
and that's not the case.
The greatest power in our
democracy is in the people,
is in the person, is in the vote.
And so, continuing to
tell our community that.
- I can't wait till the day
that we have a Latina president.
- I know, that would not be fun.
We'll paint the white
house pink, Rosa Mexican.
- I love it, I love it.
Thank you so much for your
time and for everything you do.
- Thank you, thank you
for my shitty coffee.
(laughs)
- I will take all the credit for that.
(upbeat music)
It's a wrap.
Thank you to Eva Longoria
for taking us on a trip
down memory lane.
I really appreciate it that
we're actually on campus
where she went back to get her
masters in Chicano studies.
I feel like it has a lot
to do with the purpose
that she has for life.
I think that's what I
resonate with the most.
The fact that she's using her
power to give our community
a voice, that's what the series is about.
These are the people who are
using the spotlight on them
and actually flipping the script
and using it to tell
stories of our community,
tell the stories of people whose voices
we don't get to hear that
often in the mainstream media.
And that's what inspires me.
And hopefully that's
what inspires you too.
And hopefully that's what
we keep doing in the series
until next time.
(upbeat music)